en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología
soy valentina torres sánchez y los
acompañó desde casa debido a la pandemia
de kobe 19 iniciamos este espacio en
israel donde científicos investigan si
hay algún tipo de relación entre la
vacuna de facer variante contra el
hobbit 19 y alrededor de 60 casos de
miocarditis reportados en personas
jóvenes que recibieron el fármaco medios
israelíes reportaron casos de
inflamación del músculo cardíaco 6 en
personas que recibieron la primera dosis
y 56 en ciudadanos a los que se les
aplicó la segunda inyección dos personas
perdieron la vida una mujer de 22 años y
un hombre de 35 y los 60 restantes se
recuperaron tras ser tratados en el
hospital se trata de un fenómeno
sumamente anormal si se tiene en cuenta
que más de 7 millones de personas han
recibido las dos dosis del fármaco en
ese país pues el ministerio de salud
asegura que hasta el momento no hay un
vínculo causal claro y esto es lo que
indica el laboratorio y hemos visto esta
información de israelí siempre hacemos
dos cosas en primer lugar pedir
detallada eso salió de un reporte de la
prensa y es importante recibir toda la
información para determinar lo que
realmente pasó y cómo fueron
documentados los casos de miocarditis
los síntomas y la severidad siempre
tienen que estar bien descritos porque
ya hicimos fue buscar en nuestra base de
datos donde tenemos disponible la
información de más de 200 millones de
personas que han sido vacunadas y hasta
el momento en lo que hemos visto no
hemos encontrado ninguna evidencia
significativa de esa inflamación del
músculo cardíaco los expertos reiteran
que es clave aclarar este tipo de
sucesos porque socavan la confianza de
la gente en las vacunas además recuerdan
que desde que los mayores han sido
inoculados en el mundo la enfermedad
está afectando fuertemente a los jóvenes
en entrevista con france 24 el doctor
simpson hernán de la asociación médica
israelí resaltó la importancia de
hacerse vacunar pues está comprobado que
la inmunización es la mejor oportunidad
que tenemos hasta el momento para evitar
una sintomatología grave hemos visto que
en una entidad abrumadora
gente joven infectada
y por eso no hay duda en nosotros
creemos que hay que vacunarse no
interesa con qué vacuna
la fazenda en la moderna la ganga
la china cualquiera de ellas sin vacuna
es peor que con tal de recibir una
vacuna no la mejor del mundo continuamos
en brasil donde investigadores de varias
instituciones desarrollaron un suero
contra el coi 19 a partir del plasma de
caballos que podría generar anticuerpos
hasta 100 veces más potentes que los
producidos por pacientes enfermos ahora
están en conversaciones con las
autoridades sanitarias del país para
iniciar ensayos clínicos terminando
franklin y terminando esa etapa
preclínica vamos a entrar en proceso de
pruebas junto con el instituto dor con
41 pacientes en 41 pacientes
el suero aumenta el nivel de anticuerpos
del paciente cuando es inyectado va a
hacer que aumente la producción natural
de anticuerpos de ese paciente que
exporten es paciente los responsables
del proyecto han señalado que 10
caballos han sido de los productores del
llamado plasma hiper inmune
es la materia prima para producir el
suelo tras ser aislada de la sangre
equina la sustancia es llevada a una
planta industrial donde el anticuerpo es
procesado y envasado en ampollas para la
aplicación oa pacientes los
investigadores aseguran que el
procedimiento es indoloro para los
animales y la capacidad de producción es
de 14 mil ampollas de suero por minuto
dejamos el kobe 19 y vamos a la ciudad
neerlandesa de eindhoven para conocer a
las primeras personas que desde ahora
son los ocupantes de una casa
completamente impresa en 3-d con los
respectivos permisos de las autoridades
europeas para ser habitable se trata de
un espacio de 95 metros cuadrados que
cuenta con dos habitaciones sala comedor
cocina y baños ya hay otras casas y
empresas en europa sin embargo esta es
la primera en la que toda la estructura
hecha de hormigón salió de la boquilla
de la impresora 3d expresión hecha con
leds en youtube esta especial tiene una
forma inusual y cuando la vi por primera
vez me recordó lo que veía cuando era
joven como una gran roca
al like me gusta de ese sentimiento
inmediato que me dice que es algo
interesante que viene del interior
cannes ensancha los inquilinos pagarán
alrededor de mil dólares mensuales de
alquiler en esta casa que tomo 120 horas
imprimir y la idea del proyecto que
incluye 4 casas más es encontrar formas
más sostenibles de construcción no
usaremos esta tecnología como parte de
otras combinadas con estructuras de
madera y otros materiales la respuesta
es sí y esta tecnología de fabricación
con aditivos puede agregar una forma de
personalización finalizamos fuera de la
tierra para rendir un homenaje póstumo
al astronauta michael collins que
falleció a los 90 años tras batallar
contra el cáncer collins fue integrante
de la misión apolo 11 pero contrario a
sus compañeros
neil armstrong y buzz aldrin no pisó la
luna sino que fue el encargado de
mantener la nave orbitando a 96
kilómetros sobre ese satélite natural se
le conocía como el hombre más solitario
de la historia o el astronauta olvidado
sin embargo su papel lejos de ser
irrelevante es considerado clave en la
historia de la exploración espacial
gracias por acompañarme quédense con
nosotros hay más en france 24
[Música]